guys before the video starts i'm doing
going to appeal for syria afghanistan
and ethiopia provinces inshallah people
are literally freezing we will never
live in those conditions help me reach
my target to give them some walls i've
done the seven day free trial of the
qurani app and it exceeded all my
expectations what was the system you can
build a habit with the quran buy seven
day free trial bonuses not credit card
details required at all and you decide
for yourself is it overrated or is it
underrated
so you said uh one
at a time one makes a choice because one
finds reason to make that choice where
does one find reason to make that choice
please
well that is the choice one has two like
alternatives and when one desires to do
one thing above another thing it has
reasons that is the choice itself it's
not that that's not something external
to the choice
i'm making a choice because i'm making a
choice that doesn't make any sense i'm
asking you a question where
did and your desire is makes you
responsible we can still maintain free
will uh we just mean something else with
free will because we believe that god is
the efficient cause of every event so
all actions we acquire the action and he
creates the action so acquiring makes us
responsible and creation is just a
fulfillment so there's a co-cause
carefully when he has been absolutely
annihilated by that sister
look at his facial reaction look how
those demeanor changes and look how he
turns to his computer's pc for some kind
of answers you understand that i had one
just in case
yeah feel free to to think about this um
too uh okay thank you for coming back
thanks for waiting question i appreciate
it thanks for waiting question
appreciation thanks for waiting
questions thanks for watching now he has
been shaken so badly by this girl just
this great sister so badly that this
fool this other guy who's hosting and
making her
it makes a joke
the guy literally goes zones out like is
that i'm sorry i was reading check this
out guys this is how he gets humiliated
is the true religion because it says so
in arabic hellfire hellfire
all righty then moving on seems like ap
is not interested in laughing at my
[ __ ] uh oh sorry i didn't know
what's going on
[Music]
and by the way guys i've got debate with
this fool in may and i cannot wait
to shake him and rattle him just the way
he's rattled zoned out keep an eye on
that show that's going to be in may i'll
be traveling to america inshallah a
banging post is coming out real soon
inshaallah we're going to deal with this
little pusillanimous boy until next time
assalamu alaikum